guys are looking for
obviously hot and just don't be crazy
and then maybe we'll wipe you on dates
or whatever
he's about to do a graph on what women
are looking for or how to define men
what do you think is going to be on this
graph money
status okay
natalie
i don't think my values align with with
normal people what do you think is on
there i don't know what would you have
these people are out of their [ __ ]
well we're just talking crazy stuff here
this is not like this is just you know
what what do i what do people look for
in men
i'm saying what do you think is going to
be on his chart
for men yeah
um
dick size money
would you play the the second half of
the video and the the other gentleman is
going to walk in and say what does it
work for men let's find that spot oh
there's another joke yeah it's the
universal hot crazy matrix
that was pretty good now let me ask you
like for the women watching is there a
male version of that i mean oh yeah
would it also be oh yeah it's a little
simpler if a dude is super hot okay it's
a little simpler but we can do it real
quick it doesn't take very long at all
for women this is your this is your
matrix you got your cute access and you
got your money access okay and uh if you
have there's only three sections women
have a very large no-go zone this is for
dudes who are neither hot nor have a lot
of money um you'll notice over here this
is the husband section uh once you cross
a line and have sufficient amounts of
money it is no longer relevant how hot
you are and then women have a fun zone
here where a dude is broke but hot
that is the that is the cute versus rich
matrix uh for women there you go
thoughts
i'm just i'm not a shallow piece of [ __ ]
i guess yeah
but um you know here's the thing like i
feel like when i i used to date and i
used to think like it doesn't matter how
much money someone has doesn't matter
where they are in life like i used to
think like if i love them i love them
and that's all that matters
and then you know i i did when i got
older started to think like okay where
they are in their life does show their
character it does show their
accomplishments do show who they are how
young are you for the record i am 27
years old and you're 28 20 okay 29. so
you guys are both in your late 20s fair
enough but i do think that um
i i don't think
money
i think money matters but i don't think
that we need to put the stress on it the
way we do like in this video okay i
think it's an indicator of maybe your
ambition more than anything and you're
passionate you're working thanks
ambition okay what do you have to say
amber um i agree i think it's just so
hard for me to find somebody that i
generally genuinely like spending time
with that money is just so far down on
the factor because i'm like so hard to
even enjoy somebody and i don't have the
ability to fake anything i wish
but if there's a guy who has money and i
just don't like his personality that's
just it's never gonna
[Music]
you